so i got asked this question this guy
was like hey
he dm he goes
sean big fan um
what the whatever the next sentence you
typed to me i'm gonna do it or i'll die
trying
and then he's like he's like i'm gonna
get to ten thousand dollars a month of
passive uh passive income profits after
you know and you know i'm thinking
either a i start a newsletter b
i do this other thing and this is like
all like kind of like stuff we do either
stuff we do or like topics we talk about
e-commerce newsletter or this other
thing which one do you think is going to
get me there the fastest or the best
like which one's the best path
and i was like i don't know dude this
all seemed pretty hard to get to 10k a
month like you know
if i heard if i wanted if your goal is
really 10k a month
um
you know i don't know a job we'll
probably get you there but if let's take
that off the table for a second let's
assume you don't want a job or you don't
have maybe the degree to get a
six-figure job
i was like i would just do a productized
service
[Music]
dude sean so here's the deal we are
officially more
we're popular enough that you have to
get your podcast set up right so what
i'm gonna do is i talk to ben we're
having someone come to your house and my
house and they're gonna put a two camera
set up so they're gonna like cut back
and forth but you've gotta make that
room and they'll help you but you're
gonna have to make that room look good
and it's gonna be ready every time
dude that's great um also
related to that i found a new house that
i might move into that's way nicer
and i was like uh my main motivation was
to make this podcast look better i was
like you know i kind of look like a
scrub on this podcast like you know like
right now i don't have my hair cut down
my beard trim don't have my room nice i
was like if a hundred thousand plus
people
consume this every time like
i would never go out in front of a
stadium like this
right i wouldn't even let three friends
come to my house and look at my office
like this why do i let a hundred
thousand people see the office see the
recording studio like this
simply for convenience but uh there's
that also i found on i've ever used peer
space it's like a
airbnb for rentals that are
not houses like not necessarily houses
to stay in it's like just for a venue
and there's a a place near me for 75
bucks an hour for recording podcast
that's like a two camera setup with a
sick couch and stuff like that it'd be
great for in-person stuff but if we're
not in person you know it's just me
sitting on a giant couch i'm gonna do it
i'll come out there and we'll finally do
it ben wanted me to come out there but i
didn't want to fly but whatever i'll do
it i was talking to hubspot or someone
and i was saying like hey yeah give us
budget to make our studio nice because
we're like the lowest maintenance people
you have i was like for example two
weeks ago shawn recorded a podcast with
literally just one airpod because he
didn't have a mic and the other airpod
ran out of batteries so he just used his
airpod at his laptop so like i think
we're due
we're owed one
that's hilarious um also
uh but i was gonna say oh there's this
guy
i wish i could give my shout out i don't
know what his name is but
i kind of want to steal this idea so
this guy has this course it's an
on-demand course
that is only about how to make your
video camera go from like a before to an
after and i was like
oh this is the smartest course i've ever
seen ben knows the same yeah i don't
think
ben you know his name yeah his name is
kevin shen
kevin chen yeah actually i shouldn't
shout bleep that out i'm gonna make it
my own competitor course i'll bleep this
guy out i'm not gonna copy him no but
your setup sucks dude it's like it's
like a fat person giving a person how to
lose weight
i'm the before story just wait until you
see my after you're the way before story
we all know there's the way before
there's the before and then there's the
actor
i'm currently hitting before you should
the way before was the one airpod
recording on no microphone with no light
uh yeah
and we're gonna i'm gonna do the after
and then i'm just gonna turn that into a
it's a one hour
thing and it just says here's the thing
to buy and then because here's the
problem i've watched a bunch of these
youtube tutorials and they're like oh
yeah go get the sony a5 or you can get
the a6 or you can get the d340 and it's
like all right well dude which one and
then you buy it and they're like yeah
just connect it to your computer and
then
okay see now it looks good and i was
like yeah but you like there was like
seven things in between there that like
everything went wrong
and they're like okay you know you want
to there's one guy who's like
some people show you how to put your
lights up or whatever but dude this is
the new um
like your webcam is the new
face like
your new business is basically yeah it's
your suit it's like what people see
um
like this one time this guy told me he
goes
he goes yeah dude
he's like i spent yeah he's like i got
to go with my haircut and i was like how
do you spend on a haircut because i was
like you guys nice hair and i was like
it kind of made it sound like a big deal
like i can't do anything today i gotta
go get my hair cut and i was like i just
kind of like you know it's like in the
middle of another task i'm getting my
haircut like that's kind of how i yeah
like if the great clip just so happens
to be in the mall that you're at
yeah exactly like which supercuts do you
go to and he was like he was like you
know i go to this one place she's been
cutting my hair for years i go i have a
standing appointment and i was like damn
dude you're like really into your hair
he goes your hair is like half of your
face
i was like oh [__]
that's so true
yeah but you're not into the other half
either so it's all good
right like
moisturizing
i was like damn he's right i'm just
leaving 50
up to super
cuts that ain't right
like good hairs like an extra two inches
of height as far as like you know that
goes so anyways dude um speaking of
being talk about even speaking of being
really good looking did you see the
tweet that happened today so
this woman uh this like good-looking
woman and her good-looking husband
hey she's married dude
they're both handsome um they're they're
a beautiful couple and they uh she sent
me this message basically and i shared
the the screenshots on twitter but
basically a year ago you tweeted
something i sent you the tweet i
actually forget what do you do you
remember what it was no i didn't see the
tweet what was the original tweet should
we fly is it interesting does it matter
uh she said it was like really cringe
that she even replied to it in the first
place but here i'll pull it up so
basically you said um
i have zero interest in buying a fancy
car you know what i want a personal
in-house chef i can't think of a better
way to spend money than a chef how do i
start one how do i start getting one
next week and she replied like hey hire
me i'm a chef but i've got about 32
other skills uh whatever and this guy
dm'd her and she said that they were
just talking about like i guess
the chef business or something like that
uh
yeah i mean it was clear what was going
on in the gecko but he like she said
she sent me the first message and it
just they were just like talking and
shooting the [__]
he's like hey whatever the thing you're
talking about i'm super sure tell me
more about whatever that was
well and he's here
he's from indiana and she's from ireland
and so she's in europe he's in america
and they start talking back for the dms
then they get on a call and she said
they hit it off and after two weeks of
just constant calls he booked a flight
to europe and for two weeks they they
like had this great time and then now a
year later so they're she moved to
america it's been a year about since
that tweet they're getting married in a
couple months and it was all because she
said that she listened to mfm and read
the hustle she started listening to this
she started commenting on your stuff and
my stuff he noticed that and then they
like i think his inn was like talking
about like the pod and like oh you like
them too and uh it totally worked she
sent me a picture of them they're
they're both i mean they're both tens
it's a good looking couple so uh
our new tag line is mfm getting you paid
and laid
yeah there you go
yeah and i am sure all of our listeners
are as good looking as them yeah i don't
think so but they uh
they did a good job but i was i was
showing this to my mom and i'm like see
not it's not just neckbeards that listen
to this like it's actually like you know
like real people who like shower and
stuff but it looks good i'm happy for
these people so shout out to them
maybe we should do a date night every uh
nine months
and we should just bring together
listeners and it's just be dating and
let's just see what happens it's gonna
be like like right like like you know
greg and steve everyone's gonna be named
like chris and tucker like it's gonna be
all guys like so
it's the only time if you're looking for
a man
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah exactly
we've got the tagline
too that is a pretty cool moment though
i'm glad that that happened that's kind
of crazy that that happened and uh but
ben uh producer ben young producer ben
we need
your story did you do anything bold when
you met your wife did you like this guy
a pretty bold move right slide into the
dm yeah
figure out some excuse to call each
other every day then book a flight go
over there and fall in love get married
that's kind of amazing did you either
you guys do any bold moves
uh we were set up on a blind date
and it was my boss at the time ceo uh
actually my boss is bazabos the ceo of
the company i was working for um i ran
into him one night and he was like oh do
you know katy jowers you have to take
her out and so he sent a text to both of
us that was like it sounded like a work
email he was like katie i have cc'd been
here he's a great employee and will take
you on a nice date and i was like all
right well i guess i'm locked in
why did he know that you should take her
out of date are you was she mormon too
yeah yeah this was utah so we're all
more everyone in the story is man how
tall is she
she's 511 well there that's why he's
like you guys are both big tall white
mormons you should uh
procreate again you're describing
everyone in the state of utah though
like the whole population is tall white
mormons you said it like it was a movie
twist you're like but here's the thing
i'm mormon she was mormon
it's like the end of the sixth sense
it's like he was just and i'm a guest
with this whole thing
that's awesome um so no no no no great
deal i'm sorry
dude all right i have some i have
something interesting that i saw sean i
posted a link to this subreddit to this
reddit post that i saw right before i
logged into this
uh
to the podcast and i linked it to you so
basically there's this subreddit called
fat fire that i like i've sent it to you
and every once in a while you get these
amazing stories about people because
they reveal like their income and things
like that and i've been following this
lawyer he's a 38 year old explain what
fat fire is yeah so fast people don't
know what fat fire
fire stands for financially independent
retired early traditionally
it's like a movement of people who want
to save like 500 000 to a million
dollars and live off of like 30 30 30 or
40 thousand dollars a year that's not
exactly what it means but that's like
traditionally like with the stereotype
fat fire means you want to retire in
early and be financially independent but
you want to be doing it fat so you want
to like you know save like 20 million
dollars or something like that so you
want to start a company sell and retire
and so it's people who want to retire
while they're young and uh do it by
still living living lavishly and it
sounds douchey but it's actually quite
interesting it's all like entrepreneurs
bankers tech people who like work at a
it's just like rich people [__] and
which is always fun to like be
voyeuristic and so there's this guy he's
a 38 year old personal injury lawyer
and for the past four years he's given
an update every couple of years and he
explains everything that's going on in
his business and so his background is
basically that he was a normal he went
to a good school and then worked at one
of the big law firms which is like
something that you like grind for 80
hours a week and hopefully climb your
way up and eventually you make a million
dollars a year after 10 or 15 years but
it's kind of boring and you're like kind
of like your boss is [__] for a long
time and it just kind of sucks and so he
goes you know what screw this a friend
of his got hurt and he goes hey i'll
represent you just pay me whatever's
fair and then he did and he won and then
a few other people started coming to him
just word of mouth and so he was doing
this in the evenings uh while he was
still working his main job and after a
year he quit to do his own thing that's
when his income from his moonlighting
became bigger than his normal thing so
fast forward now
i believe it's been about eight years
since he's been doing this so 2014 to
2022 and he's listed out his income as
well of his net worth breaking it down
by assets for every single year so in
year one it was three hundred thousand
dollars two six hundred thousand eight
hundred thousand one point two million
three million five point six million six
million six million and this year so far
three point three and it's going to be
eight million this year and that's
personal income basically he he has
these posts where he breaks down exactly
how his businesses work what his current
plan is what his growth challenges are
what his marketing is and basically he's
got like five attorneys that work for
him and he's slowly built up to that he
gets a little bit of cut of all that
they have they have 300 cases that they
do a year um
he talks about growth challenges which
is that they're struggling with the crm
they don't have a crm everything's done
manually manually and it's a lot of work
and one of his golden goals is to
automate a lot of stuff but it's
incredibly fascinating for two reasons
one
this is a sick business right like it's
like just a 37 year old smart person but
he doesn't seem like that particularly
extraordinary but he's like killing it
now he says that his net worth is
currently 5.8 million dollars
and his kids have a trust fund of 1.7
million and then secondly why this is
cool for a couple reasons one alex
hermosie had this business alex rosie
was a guest here he had this business
called gym launch where he basically
worked with gyms where he that you paid
him 20 or 30 000 and he set up your
whole crm and he set up all the
automated emails for onboarding and just
kind of set up the automation flow
someone should do that for these
personal injury attorneys this is
awesome they have way more money than
jim's and there's probably just as many
of them i have no idea but probably
um
i don't know what do you think about
this post this is pretty cool right
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hubspot grow better
this is great i don't go on fat fire as
much as you do um i do it from time to
time but i don't like i don't know i
need to like add it to my feed or
whatever uh but yeah this is great 38
years old 15 million 15 million net
worth not five uh 15.8
uh and then the six million annual
income is actually the more stunning
part like i'm not surprised that a
lawyer at 40 can have 15 million in in
net worth it's the 6 million in annual
income that's sort of like stunning
which makes me want to understand
this personal injury lawyer business
better like he says like you know i do
know marketing i basically just hand out
business cards plus i get referrals for
my existing clients
um but that is a ton
that is a ton of like take home from
your
like your legal practice i don't think
that's
common so i wonder what he's doing
that's uncommon like he talks about
look these cases basically like
you know it's not about more cases like
300 cases could end up being worth more
than 3 000 cases because you you know
you get paid based on the outcome you
know the the profits of the of the cases
but man that's kind of weird like isn't
it no i don't think that so this guy's
in southern california so maybe he's in
san diego so it's a pretty big city but
i think if you look at the top 20 cities
in america if you look at the billboards
it's always personal injury uh lawyers
and there's this one guy in um
in austin and austin's like a top 15
city maybe and he says that his earnings
are i forget exactly what it says his
earnings are but i looked him up on
instagram and he's got a collection of
like 15 ferraris he was in the newspaper
because he had a birthday party for his
daughter or for himself and he had like
rod stewart or someone crazy he spent
like three million on that and they
talked about his home and he was
donating checks for two or three million
dollars and that was in austin
his name was thomas i think something
thomas and
i think i know a personal injury
attorney in st louis and he's got a
mansion in miami he's got a place in st
louis where we're from i mean i think
some of these guys could
could really roll in it and re netting
10 or 20 a year
yeah this is it's wild and i like that
idea of the the gym launch for x um
i think you're right with lawyers like i
see this right now my my father-in-law
has senior living facilities
and he's always like you know i'm like
how's biz and he's like oh it's good or
it's bad but his thing is always just
like
you know we have a 64 bed facility and
every bed in the facility so like let's
say so this is like a senior living
care center so basically what he does
his model is like he'll buy one so say
it has 32 beds but it's permitted for up
to
up to 80. and just the current owner
like doesn't really have the motivation
or the construction experience and so
he'll he just looks for that first he's
like all right you have a good business
and i can expand i can just double the
number of beds which will double the net
income of this roughly which will double
the value of this property so if i'm
buying it for four this will be worth
eight to ten by the time i'm done with
it and i gotta put in two million in
construction just round numbers just for
for argument's sake
then he has a management company that
will actually like run the thing because
i was like dude do you know how to run a
senior living facility like isn't that
hard and weird and he's like well like i
don't go there like i
hired this i found one really good
property management company and they run
all my properties and i was like wow
okay she's like yeah she's been doing
this for 30 years that's what she does
and like she you know she gets it cut um
and then the other thing he was saying
who's like you know it's all about
occupancy right just like any
hospitality type of business you know
every bed they pay us on average let's
say six to eight thousand dollars per
month um
so you know if we just get like four
more bookings you know these are that
adds an extra whatever you know 30 000 a
month or whatever to our um to our
revenue which is which is great and so
he what he'll do is i'm like so every
time i ask him how's business going he's
just like oh it's good we lost two
clients uh you know we're gonna we're
gonna place another one today and i'm
like
i'm like how do you get clients and he's
basically like oh you know we kind of
like she networks with the hospitals
they know her so they send her some
people like do you advertise at all
he's like no how do i do that and i was
like oh [__] i was like like if somebody
google searches like you know senior
living
near me and like yeah your city name
like do you come up and he's like no
and there's like these aggregators like
these search engines that they like the
seo rank to the top um but
i was like i knew a guy i feel like if
you just did like dude i knew a guy who
owned one of those search engines and he
was making a couple million bucks a year
and basically he would come up on top on
google and then sell the lead for 200 to
your your guy and he would buy that lead
and then hopefully close them to make 8
000 a month
exactly and so i was like you should
either be buying these leads you should
set up some referral system you should
take you know local newspaper ads local
magazines like you know i don't know
gotta do something on the marketing side
he's just like
i don't know that like basically he
looks at marketing the way i would look
at what he says which is well like just
do a renovation and like take it from 32
beds to 64 beds and then get the permits
for the memory care from the city and
then do this right it's like what like i
gotta read this manual and figure out
like what color the elevator buttons
need to be like i'm out i just can't do
this i fail and like that's what
dude set up a google adwords account
like feels like to him and so i think
there's that arbitrage which is
basically how many people are there that
are
injury lawyers senior living centers
pool construction companies that just
simply don't know digital marketing and
like can you build either a lead gen
business or go like consult and help
them and like take a share of the
increase in revenue like jim launch it
just seems like that is one of
like um that is one of the easiest ways
to do it so i got asked this question
this guy was like hey
he dm he goes
sean big fan um
what the whatever the next sentence you
typed to me i'm gonna do it or i'll die
trying
and then he's like he's like i'm gonna
get to ten thousand dollars a month of
passive uh passive income profits after
you know and you know i'm thinking
either a i start a newsletter b
i do this other thing and this is like
all like kind of like stuff we do either
stuff we do or like topics we talk about
e-commerce newsletter or this other
thing which one do you think is going to
get me there the fastest or the best
like which one's the best path
and i was like i don't know dude those
all seem pretty hard to get to 10k a
month like you know
if i heard if i wanted if your goal is
really 10k a month
um
you know i don't know a job we'll
probably get you there but if let's take
that off the table for a second let's
assume you don't want a job or you don't
have maybe the degree to get a
six-figure job
i was like i would just do a productized
service
he's like what does that mean i was like
okay even just skip productize just a
service i was like totally
basically find one niche of a business
and figure out how what you can do that
helps them make more money so i was like
maybe it's just email marketing services
for e-commerce companies
maybe it's lead gen for pool
construction companies maybe it's um you
know this it's like you know the the gym
launch playbook where it's like yeah
i'll just do sales calls for you and
like i'll help you close ex you know new
customers every month or you know i'll
make your website convert one percent
better you know through a series of
experiments and you pay me a flat fee of
four grand a month and like that one
percent for you is gonna be worth at
least 10x more than that you know these
are the simplest things i was like and
then what do you do how do you get
clients like let's assume you don't have
any money
you create content that just talks about
like for example if you're doing
conversion rate optimization for an
e-commerce store you just post
check out what these guys do in their
add to cart you know in their cart
shopping cart that improve improves
conversion by eight percent check out
what these guys do with their email
pop-up check out what these guys do with
their checkout buttons and we did this
change and this changed this percent
well like here's a collection of the
best
you know whatever uh designs for landing
pages
and people will see that and they'll be
like oh yeah that's smart and they'll
one time you do it they'll be like ah
that's smart the second time they'll be
like those are smart third time you do
it they're like he's smart let me just
hire this guy i just want this problem
solved and like you could do that and
you can get to 10 20 30k a month of
profit
and that is a way better path than like
i think what most people
think about doing instead
yeah and also i hate that question
because i get that all the time too i'm
like i don't [__] know man what are
you good at like i i you know i i don't
know like go play in the nba like i i i
have to know like what your attributes
are
i hate that question i'm just like you
know what i mean it's the stupidest
question ever i cannot stand that
because they just want me to like tell
them what to do you like that one they
just want me to tell tell them what to
do but when you have zero contacts it's
just useless bullcrap advice
yeah i i could see that but also i don't
know i kind of empathize like
i empathize i think it's stupid i can i
can i can understand why you asked that
and think it's stupid
i understand why you're doing this
stupid thing i totally get it yeah i i i
asked that question too and now i know
it's not the right question
yeah but then you got to follow up with
what is the right question
well you just need more context you know
um
uh who's stupid now
who's stupid now stupid
well
i never said i wasn't either
dude did you know that elon musk do you
know elon musk has a sister
what kind of amazing subject is that uh
no i didn't know that i only knew about
kimball musk okay well
elon's got a sister and she owns this
thing called
passionflix.com it's basically like uh
audio erotica i believe like like like
you know like uh
it's the tagline i'm familiar yeah
the
more of a video guy myself but all right
i guess you could always close the tab
the subject or the tagline is
passionflix get your passion on romance
on demand for six dollars a month
and uh it's basically romance novels
which we had talked about uh in your
ears i guess
like audiobooks um but i mean do we
do we get credit for this like does elon
musk's sister listen to the pod because
we've been talking about this for a long
time and
i think you should tell the story
because the pod's much bigger than the
first time tell your story about the
romance novel thing tell first the story
about how you did it for the hustle as a
marketing stunt and then what you did
with uh with our buddy all right so for
the hustle when we the very first
article we ever launched we had to come
out with a bang and i knew this guy who
basically would plagiarize others other
people's books on how to sleep with
women and he would get a filipino to
rewrite it so it passed the kindle
plagiarism like filter and then he would
game it by buying reviews and he was
making fifty to sixty thousand dollars a
month and like i would joke with them
but i was like dude hey this is super
unethical and b you don't even sleep
with women like you don't know anything
about this topic i can't believe you're
like living this live but whatever he
was making money and so we wrote an
article about that when it first came
out and to prove that it was legit
because a lot of people didn't believe
us we go fine watch we're going to copy
this and do and do it and instead of
doing in like the how to sleep with
women category uh we did it for romance
cat the romance category because if you
look at the the
the liquidity of the marketplace on
amazon romance novels has the most
amount of buyers and also like the most
amount of transactions like these women
are always buying this stuff and so we
like
looked at like what the popular
categories were and there was like women
who want to have sex with like a
werewolf there was like women who want
to have sex with um like military people
and so we made like a like fantasies
right yeah until we made like a military
guy a rich billionaire guy right that's
50 shades of grey a vampire that's
twilight right that that's fantastic
vampire that's right so we made it like
a military vampire werewolf guy like
combined all of them and then we found
like
like the title is that really what you
did yeah well we found what we did after
the title so we found a book that was
good and we just like plagiarized it and
then like made the title like in the
description about like a vampire
werewolf military guy a billionaire i
forget like it was like a joke we did
all of them
and then we game the system so in a
couple weeks or in a week we were the
number one best selling in a particular
category and we like changed our
linkedin so like best-selling author and
yeah because because we were like how do
we get like speaking gigs now and
which i didn't know at the time but we
actually plagiarized the largest romance
publisher in the world harlequin books
and they called us i thought they were
going to like sue us because they sent
this angry email and and and then in the
email or on the call they're like look
we get it you're you're making you're
not really making fun of romance novels
you're making fun of this like kindle
thing which we agree is silly but you
use us as an example no big deal we get
it but you got to take it down so we
took it down so whatever and so i've
always been curious about this industry
and so about two years ago three maybe
three years ago my friend ramon and i
we created this website called
captivating oh no what was it called the
first book was called captivating claire
uh what was this
that was the book of the book that we
launched captivating claire what was the
book was a short book romantic we
launched a website called
shortromantic.wordpress.com
and we basically
we got someone on fiverr
we got someone by the way
romantic.wordpress.com is the least
short and least romantic
yeah it was horrible and so we uh we
created short but romantic and we
and we got someone on fiverr to write
like a part one of like a like a sexy
story thing like i frankly i didn't even
read it and then we got another fiverr
guy to narrate it and then we put it on
the website and we said part one of like
captivating claire or whatever it was
and it was like read the story and then
at the end it said do you want part two
sign up here for twenty five dollars a
month and most of them wanna use one of
these every single day and we put ads on
facebook for it and i made like i found
like this girl that i went to college
with and i was like hey can i use your
face on this
uh this website act like you're the
author and like you're the one behind it
because it wouldn't look good if it was
me and so we did and we got like 500 in
revenue in like 12 hours because the ad
rate was crazy and if you went to the
website people were commenting on this
saying like this story is amazing i love
this i want more of this you saw it
right
yeah i remember the i remember seeing
the prototype and i was it was like
dude sam is a genius man like i love how
you spin these things up i love the
names that you pick
i love the like the speed to proto speed
to launch
um i love the way that you did the test
which was most people would go and
spend months trying to find an author
and write a book and you were like
you know you just were like okay
werewolf military
you know
blonde girl named claire claire wants to
feel
uh captured no claire wants to feel you
know
contemplated no
captivated yes sorry captivating claire
um claire wears a red dress and she
bumps into this billionaire and his hand
grazes her thigh and that's it we got it
all right
i saw the website and i just saw your
fingerprints all over it so i was like i
remember being so impressed and i tried
we invested in our buddy for this i was
like dude this is a great market to be
in and if you're kind of growth hacking
you're gonna do this
and nobody else is doing this right it
was like there's so little competition
because most
most serious people could never bring
themselves to do this so it's just
you're to compete with the other
not so serious people that are out there
on earth and like i would put our skills
up there with any of them yeah
absolutely and it was a good idea
actually but
the thing that was that the thing that
was the thing was like i don't give a
[__] about this neither did he you know
like this was exactly what we weren't
exactly fueled by this uh passion to
create these like sex novels and so we
kind of like shut it down but a listener
a podcast listener did something like
this and he spun it up i think to ten
thousand in revenue a month like really
fast right
yeah that's what i think so and then
also um there was a difference i think
there's a difference between like
literal audio porn and then like romance
novels and this i think passionflix that
you love what elon musk's sister is
doing is the uh
the romance novels uh on demand 5.99 a
month so i actually think this is a
great idea
um
you know i i basically i think there's a
great idea if you're good at internet
marketing and you're like you know got a
good sort of sense of humor about
yourself i think that this is a
a business that will work if you apply
enough pressure it's hard though to like
stay excited about it for a long time
unless you just love selling widgets in
fact our buddy ramone
the first time i met him you introduced
me to him we go out to a lunch
he's telling me his life story and his
life story is full of like substance
it's like
you know i was raised in the netherlands
and then like you know i had this i was
kind of like out on my own at a young
age and then like i have i'm a single
father to my son and blah blah blah like
whatever he had a bunch of things that
were like you know these journeys
throughout his life's lifetime that were
like you know these these i mean i
trained mma like he seemed like a dude
who like you know
he really kind of like you know was
self-made in many ways
and then i was like so do you like i
kind of expected him to be like you know
so that's why i'm working on this thing
that has like this deep meaning also
and i was like so what was your last
business he's like oh um
created a soap opera blog and i sold it
for 10 million dollars
and i was like what
i was like because you love soap operas
you're like no i've never seen one in my
life
what the hell and i was like how did
this work he's like
and there's a he's the second episode of
this podcast so if you scroll all the
way back to the second episode i think
it's ramon it's one of the best episodes
ever that's been on the podcast feed but
basically he's like yeah i just went on
facebook and there was a arbitrage
opportunity where like you could buy
facebook page likes
facebook wanted to promote pages so you
could get you could advertise a page
for like you could get a like for like a
cent and i just figured out oh cool once
i get them to like my page i could post
a link then i'll get into my website and
like okay that costs like seven cents to
get them to my website and then google
adsense can give me
9 cents or 12 cents or whatever like
there's some like money arbitrage there
so he's like so then i just had to
figure out what is the um
you know what's the best category like
so i spun up like 22 facebook pages
about every niche i could think of
and yeah his niche was it was like
it was like wwf wrestling and like
soccer and like politics and just a
bunch of crazy stuff yeah oh every
interest you could think of and he's
like okay which one's the best and he
said the top three i think were
wrestling
i know number one was like right-wing
conservative politics yeah which
you know turned out to be like what
facebook you know really
like overran facebook also and he was
like i just don't want to do this it
doesn't make anyone happy yeah he
yeah so that one he's like all right i'm
gonna scratch that out he goes then the
next two are wrestling and soap operas
and he's like all right let's do soap
opera
he never really told me that part but
whatever so uh details so he he's like
all right well what do people care about
they care about like spoilers like
what's gonna happen on tomorrow's days
of our lives and it turns out you could
just like buy or like you could just
sign up to get the like
the sneak peek of like the synopsis of
what happens tomorrow and he would just
like publish that as a long-form thing
and he'd have he hired some people to
write for it and so some women were
writing for this stuff whatever so he
was doing that and he ends up selling
the thing for 10 million in cash
basically it was making like 3000
it was very profitable yeah
and so you you you met him he reached
out to you from the hustle he goes
uh here's my story you know i want to
tell it and you were like
no way this sounds fake and he's like
well here's my analytics and here's my
bank account like go ahead and look
and you were like what and you guys met
you know you guys like best friends so
you introduced me you're like hey
i you and the email you go
sean meet ramone i you're like
uh sean's a good buddy smart guy nice
like you know normal intro stuff like
sean this is ramon i trust ramon with my
life
[Laughter]
how do you remember that and
because it stuck out to me right i was
like so i don't know this is one of
those writing things i'm like wow that
was amazing and then i met ramon and i
also now trust ramon in my life he's
just that kind of guy and so
he told me at that meeting he goes i was
like so you just you just you'll just
work on whatever or like for your next
thing you know or you can do something
like soap ops or whatever he goes you
see this cup and there's like a little
like you know at a restaurant the water
cups are the shitty plastic ones he goes
um
if i could just move this cup from here
to here and it's like i make 10 and i
make a dollar doing that
then i'm the i'm a cup salesman like
he's listening i'll sell anything like
and so what ended up happening was he
was gonna do this romance thing and you
guys spun up this test and it started to
work
and um but one of his other businesses
that he had bought was like started to
work even better and so he just kind of
had he tried to both for a little while
but he's like when that other one was
equally as weird it was a dog ramp
business for wiener dogs so they can get
on the couch
eventually it's even worse than the
plastic cup he's like
do you have a wiener dog no uh well if
you did
you know that if they tried to jump on
or off the bed they could get hurt
i i guess so yeah we making we making
sell ramps for wiener dogs to get on and
off the bed i was like
what
and he was like
yeah we'll do like you know 7 million
this year i was like what the hell and
so you know then that business grew like
crazy or whatever
um
and so i was like wow this guy is like
you know this guy he was just so
different than everybody else in silicon
valley i loved it i loved how different
he was he lived here
but it was like an alien living in
silicon valley like he just did not have
anything to do with software or venture
capital or like
high-tech stuff he was literally like a
like a cup salesman wandering around
silica valley making millions of dollars
selling like the most arbitrary like
you know gadgets like you know fidget
spinners to you know like elderly when i
first met him um he was wearing like
sweatpants and like a shirt with holes
in it and like old jordans and i was and
he's like a huge like big white dude and
i'm like
and he has an accent you know and i was
talking like what who is this guy and we
start walking back to his car um because
i was going back to my office and i was
walking him to his car and i see he had
a brand new tesla at the time the nicest
fanciest tesla was like 150 000 i was
like oh sick car
he was like thanks bro had to pay all
cash for because i don't have a credit
score and i was like
what
i guess you're legit
yeah and we make him sound braggy but he
is the opposite of braggy like
he'll just be like
like he'll just show up with something
or like like i don't know like he'll do
something that you're like that makes no
sense whatsoever and then when you dig
in
it's because he like always takes the
hard weird path to do stuff in this
hilarious way and it's what makes him
incredible i love it yeah he's crazy um
like he got diagnosed with like a
herniated disc and then like on the way
home from the doctor like signed up for
an iron man and it's like what are you
doing why are you choosing i i i did the
iron man why did you choose violence
i did the iron man with him it was me
him and silly and um
ramon literally got last he got last
that they he he was so slow that he
didn't train at all he just showed up
and when he got and when he showed up he
had this bike and he was like hey could
someone show me
how i use these shoes that clip into the
pedals like you didn't know how to like
he was like riding his bike for like the
first time like taking the tag off of it
and uh it's an iron man it's really hard
and he got dead last but he finished
like
there was there like the golf cart was
rolling behind him and it was getting
dark at night and they were gonna try
they're about to pull him off the course
but he like pushed him off because i'm
finishing it
[Laughter]
that's incredible
um all right let's do let's do some
other ones i got some uh okay i got i
got an idea and then a really i got a
bad idea that i have and then a really
good idea for a company that i just
heard about which one do you want the
good one
do you want the better or the bad
all right so the great one there's a
company called ghost um that i just
heard about so this story to me is kind
of incredible
so if you go to the wordpress computer
no it's a new one so g s t g g h s t so
it's ghost without the o
um i think it's ghost.io is the name of
it oh this is already two new age for me
i'm out no no you're gonna you're gonna
appreciate this you're gonna
you're out but i'm gonna bring you back
here
so i heard about this because uh this
guy who's like a vc somewhere he goes
back in 2020
um our team started to notice a big
shift that was going on with like stores
like walmart target like any big store
was that basically remember when covet
happened and like the supply chain shut
down and like the [__] ship got stuck
in the canal and like everything was
just bad like shipping container prices
went through the roof and so everybody
had like a shortage right when demand
went like through the roof because
everybody was at home everybody was
ordering tons of products and um we're
all getting stimulus checks and stuff
like that right so that's like demand
went way up
to shop because people couldn't go do
experiences
and supply went way down and it was like
this crazy situation and so what
happened was retailers basically they
ordered more to try to catch up because
nobody knew how long the pandemic stuff
would go and also like the stuff that
got delayed like finally showed up but
what that created
was like this huge glut of excess
inventory over a trillion dollars of
excess inventory was kind of like the uh
the guess and so these guys these these
venture capitalists sort of noticed this
trend and they posted this 26-page pdf
called the inventory apocalypse is
coming and they were just like look we
are looking at this like a combination
of people returning things the supply
chain glut and then brands over ordering
to try to keep up with like this the
explosion and e-commerce right like um
there's just too much inventory on hand
and this is all playing out now like
that was in 2020 2021 something like
that now in 2022 if you go look there's
these amazing charts of like
oh if you notice all the every brand is
like discounting like crazy right now
they're like oh
40 off summer sale semi-annual sale like
liquidation whatever and it's because
everybody has way too much inventory to
hold and so um
and like target and walmart i think have
come out and said some crazy public
numbers ben see if you could find it
like how much excess inventory is on the
shelf some absurd number so anyways
these guys put this out and at the same
time this startup gets started by this
guy josh and d
and um and and d is kind of well known
in like the kind of like e-commerce
world um and so they they go and they
start this company basically what they
do is they they're creating like a
marketplace or a clearinghouse
so any it's called ghost because it's
like any retailer rather than doing a
huge discount which kind of like it kind
of cheapens your brand it sort of just
pulls forward revenue that like your
customers probably would have spent full
price but like in order to move
inventory you kind of like
you you gave it away cheaper and you you
know you sort of eroded your premium
prices or whatever um it basically
connects them to the liquidators of the
world so there's like
uh tj maxx ross marshalls like those
types of companies but there's also just
like international versions of those
companies there's like boutiques and
wholesalers that could carry your stuff
uh there's basically like a way to like
get rid of inventory that's on your
shelf that you're directly selling and
you could sell it wholesale for somebody
else to kind of move you'll take a
discount with them and that's better
than giving a discount to your customers
who like then they'll get trained to
expect and wait for 30 40 discounts
rather than paying the premium price i'm
backing so this is awesome
i knew you come back in their site has
five words on it and it's beautiful i
look at their site and it's literally
five words we make your inventory
disappear and the but the way that it
looks
a smoky cloud like a go like something
evaporated right behind yeah
and then basically what it seems like
what they're doing is they're creating a
private marketplace so this is key right
like it's got to be private it can't be
public and it's a marketplace between
your retailer who has excess inventory
and these wholesalers and liquidators
who will take this sort of like excess
inventory they'll pay you know they'll
get it at a huge discount and then
they'll flip it on their own that's
their business so it's kind of
connecting these two
through um through this b2b marketplace
and i think the thing is growing like
crazy so i think they said um
let's see in the first year i believe
they got to
um
multi-million dollar net revenue so not
gmv uh profitably and they're like not
even launched yet like you got to like
sign up to do a demo and [__] like that
with them but just knowing what i know
about like what's going on in e-commerce
i could tell you this thing is going to
be big like i need to chase these guys
down to go invest in this because
this is a real problem and
marketplaces are the best type of
internet business
but like you it sort of feels like all
the it's like all the good ones are tail
the good guys are taking it's like ah
all the good marketplaces are taken like
someone did it for you know amazon did
it for this ebay did it for that you
know etsy does it for crafts it sort of
feels like there's no marketplaces left
i think this could be that one of those
multi-billion dollar marketplaces that
comes out
well it's not a marketplace it's just
software isn't it
no it's a marketplace they're connecting
buyers and sellers they're connected
they don't tell the retailers but so the
the fee they don't charge a fee to the
people for using their software it's
it's just they'll set it up for free
which is probably it's a huge
integration process they set it up for
free and then they make the transaction
they make a
transaction fee
that's my guess so i think it's probably
similar i think one of the closest
analogy is a company called fair which
also does something similar so fair is
like i have an e-commerce brand i want
other retailers like you know
susie's you know gift shop to carry my
product well it would be consumed time
consuming to go find all the susie's
corner shops contact them sell them my
services create purchase orders and like
manage that whole thing so fair created
a marketplace to do that and it's a like
10 billion dollar company or something
like that it's like one of the one of
the faster growing startups that exists
um this is doing that but more on the
like
larger liquidator types like more like
the tj maxx ross like uh types
versus um
you know just like kind of
so-and-so's boutique shop that wants to
carry your stuff dude this is sick yeah
you're right i'm in this is actually
amazing um i'm eager to see how this
plays out there's nothing on on the
internet about him though so like when i
research it i can't find a thing
yeah i think they literally just came
out of stealth yesterday basically so um
that's that's how we saw it um
let me tell you uh okay now can i tell
you my bad idea it's also in the
ecommerce space
so
how do we want to put let me sell you
let me sell you on this let me turn on
the charm a little bit
sam you're a good looking dude um in
fact i would say
whatever you wear tends to look good i
feel like if i almost wore that same
shirt it wouldn't look as good right
because you got the body you don't need
you don't need to go pay you know crazy
amounts of money at you know whatever
scotch and soda our favorite brand here
at my first million you don't got to go
pay for the fancy stuff because honestly
if you dress in basic blacks and whites
neutral colors um you'll look good and
in fact thank you there are a lot of
people that are out there that may not
be as fit as you but they do
subscribe to the same philosophy which
is they're kind of just wanna opt out of
the fashion game like i went to
lululemon to go i just wanted something
that's high quality that fits well
and i went and i found a pair of shorts
and a t-shirt and um
the shorts were 85 and the t-shirt was
like you know whatever 77 dollars for
one right and so if i just wanted to
have
really awesome basics like high quality
basics
that are
premium premium like material and fit
but uh i don't care about the brand name
i'm not looking for the status
uh where would i go today to get that do
you have a place in mind where i might
go for something like that for playing
t-shirts clean fresh teas those are my
10 t-shirts that fit pretty good and
that's mostly it for for for basic [__]
and so there's there's that there's like
let's say italic i think italic does
this with uh i think i don't know if
you're also an investor italic i am but
like no but i do it with
cool stuff like handbags and scarves and
like a lot of designery type of stuff
it's like a wider selection
but i think that somebody can go create
the costco for clothes and what do i
mean by this i think you can create a
business model that flips it on its head
instead of paying
the 4x 5x 6x 7x markup that you pay
today when you go buy a shirt and you
buy a shirt for 25 dollars that shirt
probably costs five dollars to make
is that true so
yeah so you're gonna you're i think on
average you're gonna be paying somebody
something between three and four x it's
like a normal markup and then if you
once you get into like lululemon and
luxury you're gonna be paying more like
probably six or seven x is my guess here
um they're public so you could go find
their their actual like margins but like
let's assume that's what about like a
louis vuitton thing what about like a
500 gucci shirt
those are different you're buying those
literally for the status um so let's
let's put them as a separate category
i'm focusing on more of like you go buy
something from nike or from lululemon or
aloe yoga or like whatever these brands
that are like
you're just trying to have a high
quality version of
a fairly basic uh thing but there's like
some status component what i'm saying is
let's strip away the status so i'm
saying basic girl stuff
yeah you create a company called
neutral
and neutral basically just
it opts out of the fashion game and says
first of all i don't need your status i
don't need your brand name second of all
i don't need your fancy designs
third i don't need to pay 5x markups
because what a waste like what if i just
want to pay for the actual cost of the
goods and so what it is it's a
membership like costco where costco's
model is you pay whatever 100
something-ish bucks a year for the
membership and then they give you all
the groceries at cost plus 10
and the 10 is just their like the labor
and the stocking and the the stuff it
takes to actually like move the goods
around
um
and so because of that you get
incredible value out of costco moms love
shopping at costco for that reason
and they're not sacrificing on quality
they just are sacrificing on the fluff
the packaging the branding the shelves
the store experience and they say screw
that i don't need to have a fancy
display in the store i don't need to
have fancy packaging like just give me
the stuff raw um i'll pay the at the
actual
goods cost plus 10
and i'll pay you the membership fee
because hey for me i make back the
membership fee within you know my first
month or two of shopping with you i
think somebody could do that with all
basics for clothing and just say we're
gonna go get the same quality as like
whatever the highest quality you know
fit and and materials are for like you
know these fancy little lemon type
brands
and just provide it at the actual cost
so you'd be buying like that same shirt
for for eight or nine dollars and it's a
step up from like
haynes and h m or whatever but you're
getting it and the marketing is that hey
you're paying nothing for the brand name
in fact there's no brand on this it's
like brandless right um
all you got to do is pay the membership
fee and make this happen now the counter
argument is there was a company that
tried to do this called brandless they
tried to do it with like homeware and
[__] like that they went yeah i think
that's a part of business i think that
was harder i think i think i think it's
amazing i think the problem
there's basically like i asked myself
like two or three questions when i'm
like looking at which projects to start
the it's basically like do people want
this
and can i pull it off
this one falls into the second category
do people want this yeah obviously it's
not going to be hard to get people to
buy this [__] can i possibly pull that
off that sounds so challenging like
your experience seems challenging
uh pulling it off
like
what like
getting the products like just the
logistics of them having tons and tons
of skus um like that seems really hard
uh trying to get members to sign up
profitably seems a bit of a challenge is
uh italic able to get uh
do they have any profit or no
uh i mean i can't really say if they
profit or not but like you know
they're doing well as in they're growing
so they are getting members to sign up
uh people are buying into the value
proposition they're retaining the
question is like you know
there's some payback period and is that
you know if that payback period is like
you know one month wow this is one of
the best businesses ever if it's 12
months okay you know it's going to be
it's going to be more cash intensive
well you're the type of business you
have an ecom company do you think would
you ever work on this
i wouldn't work on it just because
knowing what i know now about e-commerce
i'm like oh there's easier ways to win
but if i was gonna work in e-commerce i
think an idea like this is a better idea
than 99 of e-commerce ideas because i
think you'll end up with subscription
revenue i think you're differentiated
and i think you appeal to the lowest
common denominator so you're like
you're not like everybody needs shirts
so like there's some brands like cuts
and fresh clean tees these brands have
scaled to like 100 million plus in
revenue
in i don't know three or four years and
you look at it you're like dude really
it's just a t-shirt brand and they're
doing just the t-shirts like you know
well like this they're not offering it
at the factory cost and they're not
offering it on subscription right so
that's a key difference here but the
fact that they've been able to scale
that much without it to me is like
extremely impressive and it just sort of
speaks to the fact that like
everybody needs shirts
and
it's like an everybody problem whereas
like like my ecommerce are like we
talked about ramon's dog ramp thing like
that only works if you have not only a
dog but a small dog not even really a
small dog like a small dog that might
get hurt and can't get up and down
stairs or a bed very easily and you want
that dog that applies to me that applies
to me like i have three of alpha paws
ramps in my house because like my dog is
like this tiny little baby dog you have
like this massive self-sufficient dog
that like you know has like a college
degree so like you know your dog doesn't
need like a a hand me down to like they
are like a ramp to like you know help
him up uh you know onto a couch
[Laughter]
dude my dog doesn't even drink water
from a bowl i have to like carry her to
the sink and i
get this
[Laughter]
my hand is a small bowl and she drinks
only fresh water from my hand
just keep it outside for a week it'll
toughen up like
how are you so soft dude
you uh you just interviewed this guy
rich roll who like does all these
interviews and [__] and you're like
you're like the least like you don't
even leave your house
like he was like yeah i did this
competition it was uh you know fantastic
challenge 300 mile run across three
nights
and like i was like what like
[Music]
[Laughter]
i was like i went to target last week
yeah like
no i didn't i instagramed it from target
last week but like i had to step foot
outside to bring the groceries into my
home and it was like my toe got a little
cold
how are your dogs that bad
uh you know whatever you know like dogs
start to look like their owner like you
know my dog is like a spoiled little
brat and i'm spoiled a little brat about
life too i don't know we
we suit each other well
when my dog was young uh like every once
in a while like i would just be like i'm
just not gonna feed you until you behave
like
and it worked
my dog doesn't eat dog food
nor does she like chicken or like
anything that normal my dog only eats
clover four percent cottage cheese
that's freshly scooped into her bowl
mixed with a little bit of dog food with
an appetizer bone before it she won't
eat it if you don't do that she's like
cool
i'll die
i'll just die
if you just want me to die like she'll
go five days without eating unless she
gets her cottage cheese
oh my god
that's your fault that this is crazy i
can't believe you for sure it's my fault
how old is the dog when will it die
oh well bro come on
i mean like how long like how long will
you when will it die
how long will you own this animal for
forever a hundred years that's how long
of my dog
my dog is getting close to dying and i'm
gonna be hilarious but i'm getting his
i'm getting his face tattooed on me and
i'm just
i'm gonna have a tattoo of a massive
pitbull face on my body and i think it's
gonna be like the greatest thing ever
they're gonna like people are gonna i'm
just gonna be like this this like
walking walking like what the [__] are
you like this like yuppie bougie tech
guy with pitbull tattoos on them i'm
gonna be like driving people are gonna
be like they're not gonna know what to
think it's to be wonderful
yeah that's going to be not even in your
bottom three worst tattoos
or i did like 12 year olds we should
leave
you gotta just stop the recording when
we cross whatever that line is you gotta
just be like
like we won't even realize that it
stopped recording
for your own good i cut you guys off
like
the elementary school teacher like sam
we took a gold star off your chart after
that comment
yeah by the way you weren't here the
other day ben and we were like talking
about something and we were like [__]
this sucks without ben like our moral
compass we don't know if this is right
or wrong
keeping you guys on the straight and
narrow
all right well what do we think i think
that was pretty good
[Music]
you